ladies and gentlemen a great thrill from
a two-time Academy Award winner Miss
Jane Fonda
I hope the Screen Actors Guild will
forgive me for what I'm about to say but
every year during the Academy Awards at
some stray moment during the evening a
thought comes to my mind that none of
these awards would be given out in fact
there wouldn't be any awards if it
weren't for the work of the screenwriter
at the very beginning of this evening of
celebration Karl Malden said that movies
have helped change the world need I add
that each little change had its
inception when some gifted woman or man
sat down before a blank piece of paper
and put down two of the most awesome
challenging words in the English
language fade in to all the
screenwriters who helped change our
personal world thank you from the bottom
of my heart the nominees for Original
Screenplay are Woody Allen for crimes
and misdemeanors
Tom Schulman four Dead Poets Society
Spike Lee or do the right thing
Steven Soderbergh for Sex Lies and
videotapes and Nora Ephron for When
Harry Met Sally
and the Oscar goes to
Tom Schulman four Dead Poets Society
thank you every writer should have the
kind of support that I had during the
making of this movie Peter Weir was such
a spectacular director the producer
Steven half Paul wit and Tony Thomas
gave such loving support the studio is
incredible Jeff Katzenberg David
Hoberman all the rest of them thank you
I'd like to thank Robin Williams and a
perfect cast a great crew my parents
Jean and herb and my wife Miriam who
supported me during the terrible years
when I couldn't get a job in this town
and Thank You Academy I really
appreciate this from the bottom of my
heart
you